على هامش الاجتماع مشاهدينا في وارسو
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو نشراتها وكاله
لمتظاهرين في العاصمه البولنديه وارسو
يحملون لافتات تطالب الرئيس الامريكي
بطائرات الاف 16
في هذه الاثناء تبنى مجلس هدوم الروسي
تعليقها مشاركه موسكو في معاهده نيو ستارت
وذلك وفقا لمشروع قانون مقدم من الرئيس
الروسي فلاتيمر بوتين واتهم رئيس مجلس
الدوم الروسي فيتش سلافا الولايات المتحده
بتدمير بنيه الاستقرار الدولي بتوقفها عن
الوفاء بالتزاماتها ورفضها لمقترحات روسيا
بشان قضايا الامن العالمي
انا وكاله الانباء الروسيه ريانوفسكي نقلت
عن وزاره الدفاع ان موسكو ستواصل الامتثال
للقيود المفروضه على عده من حاملات
الصواريخ النوويه في معاهده نيو ستارت
الجديده حتى بعد تعليقها وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو ستواصل
لالتزامها بالقيود المفروضه على عدد
الصواريخ التي يمكن نشرها للفتره المتبقيه
من المعاهده التي من المقرر ان تنتهي عام
في غضون ذلك اعتبر رئيس روسيمير بوتين ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا هي امتداد للمعارك التي
لا تزال مستمره على حدود روسيا التاريخيه
جاء ذلك خلال حضوره حفلا تحت اسم حماه
الوطن في موسكو
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه نحن اجتمعنا هنا
اليوم لنحتفل وانا سمعت القياده العسكريه
اليوم بان المعركه لا تزال مستمره على
حدودنا التاريخيه ومن اجل مواطنينا
ويقود هذه المعارك اولئك الابطال من بينهم
من يقفون الى جانبنا اليوم فهم يقاتلون
بشجاعه وببساله ونحن نعتز ونفتخر بهم
واليوم الدوله باكملها تدعمهم وفي هذا
الصدد ومن اجل حمايه مصالحنا وشعبنا
وثقافتنا واراضينا يعتبر شعبنا كله من
حماه الوطن
حتى وزير الخارجيه المجاري زيجارته على
وقف اطلاق النار واجراء محادثات سلام بشان
اوكرانيا لمنع مزيد من تصعيد الحرب
وتحويلها الى صراع اوسع ودعا الى انهاء
فوري للاعمال العدائيه بعد خطابين القاهما
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن والرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قال انه سلط الضوء على
خطوره المواجهه
نعود من جديد الى حيثيات وتفاصيل وكذلك
المنتظر من اجتماع مجموعه بخرص تسعه من
وارسو ينضم لنا مفد العربيه حسين قنيبر
حسين اهلا بك معنا تبعنا كلمه بايدن تبعنا
من بعده كلمه
مفتوحه للاعلام حظرتها ماذا عن الكواليس
نعم في الواقع ريم الكواليس تحمل تباينات
وبعض الخلافات بين بعض الدول الاعضاء فيما
يعرف بمجموعه بوخارست تسعه وهذه الدول
ربما تسميتها مهمه لنعرف مغزى التباينات
هي بلغاريا تشيك يا سلوفاكيا استونيا
رومانيا هنغاريا وبولندا من بين هذه الدول
التسع هناك دوله هما بلغاريا وهنغاريا
تتحفظان بل تتشددان في رفضها للدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا خاصه حكومه اقصى اليمين
في هنغاريا برئاسه فيكتور ترى انه لا يعود
لدول اوروبا الشرقيه ان تقدم دعما عسكريا
لاوكرانيا على الاقل بلده لم يقدم دعما
عسكريا بلغاريا تندرج في السياق نفسه
لناحيه رفض الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا وان
كان رصدها اق حده هذا ما تحمله الكواليس
التي تشير الى انه يسار حاليا في هذه
الاثناء التي نتحدث فيها الى محاوله
التوافق على صياغه موحده لنص اعلان مشترك
لكن الامر لا يبدو يسيرا لان الولايات
المتحده تسعى لتوحيد مواقف دول اعضاء
مجموعه بوخارست تسعه وذلك تمهيدا لاجتماع
القمه
الذي سيعقد في فيلينيوس عاصمه ليتوانيا في
الثاني عشر والثالث عشر من حزيران يونيو
المقبل ولكن لا يبدو انه سيكون بالامكان
توحيد كل مواقف الدول التي ذكرتها خلال
تعداد للدول الاعضاء في مجموعه بوخارست 9
ريم حسين هذه التباينات هل تخص الرؤيه
العامه تفاصيل العمليه والحرب الاوكرانيه
او يمكن ان يكون هناك كذلك طرح لمقترحات
نتحدث عن امك التسليح اكثر كم واكثر تطور
وهذا ما تطلبه اكياس هل يمكن ان تكون هذه
نقطه مطروحه
نعم هذه واحده من النقاط المطروحه في
الواقع هذه التباينات التي اشرت اليها لها
خلفيات اقتصاديه عسكريه تاريخيه لا ننسى
انه من الناحيه التاريخيه الدول التسعه
التي ذكرتها كانت من ضمن الكتله الشرقيه
المؤيده للاتحاد السوفيتي السابق والتي
كانت منضويه تحت اسم حلف وارسو ومن
المفارقات ان وارسو التي كانت رمزا للكتله
الشرقيه المؤيده للاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
باتت رمزا لحلف الناتو الحلف الخصم الذي
حملت وارسو طويلا اسم حلف مناقض له اذا
خلفيه تاريخيه ثمه بقايا يعني لا اقول
تعاطفا تاريخيا مع روسيا وانما هناك حذر
من بعض هذه الدول خصوصا الدولتين اللتين
ذكرتهما لناحيه ان يصبح العداء مطلقا
لروسيا هناك دول تتحفظ على ذلك هذه
الخلفيه التاريخيه الخلفيه الاقتصاديه بعض
الدول التي ذكرتها الحد الادنى للاجور
فيها لا يتجاوز 250 يورو هذا لا يمكنها من
ان ترصد مبالغ ماليه كبيره لميزانياتها
الدفاعيه الاهم من بينها مثلا بولندا
تطالبها الولايات المتحده ان ترفع
ميزانيتها العسكريه تقول انها رفعت
ميزانيتها العسكريه لتصبح 4% من الناتج
المحلي الخام وهذه نسبه مرتفعه نسبيا من
مقارنه مع بعض الدول الاخرى تقول وارسو
ايضا ان
20.4% من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه ستذهب هذا
العام لشراء اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه حديثه
دول اخرى ربما لا تستطيع القيام بهذا
الجهد المالي وايضا سبب ثالث يتعلق بخشيه
هذه الدول على مخزونها العسكري لو قدمت
دعما كبيرا عسكريا لاوكرانيا فيها ستخشى
على مخزونها العسكري لانه بعد الحرب
البارده عده دول في اوروبا بينها دول في
اوروبا الغربيه والشماليه فرنسا على سبيل
المثال كانت بدات بعد الحرب البارده بت
بعضا من مخزونها العسكري لانها اعتبرت ان
قوتها النوويه كافيه لذلك هذه الاسباب
مجتمعه تحول دون التوافق الدول المجتمعه
هنا في القصر الرئاسي البولندي الواقع
خلفي على اعلان مشترك يسار على محاوله
التوافق عليه حاليا سنبقى في انتظار اي
شيء يرشح عن هذا الاجتماع او اتشكرك جزيل
الشكر مفاده العربيه حسين قنيبر من وارسو
شكرا لك
قبل المتابعه نشير الى بعض العواجل وردت
من الصين الصين الرسميه في ربط مع كل ما
يحدث ستقول سنبقى موضوعيين وعلى الحياد
فيما يتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه سنلعب دورا
في تسويه الصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وتقول الصين رسميا نثمن رغبه روسيا في
تسويه الصراع مع اوكرانيا سلميا تبقى
العين على هذه العواجل نتابع بقيه الاخبار
ذات الصله حيث دعم مؤسس مجموعه العسكريه
الخاصه يفجيني بريكوجين دعا المواطنين
الروس للضغط على وزاره الدفاع لتزويد
مقاتل المجموعه بالذخيره وذلك في دعوه غير
مسبوقه تعكس مدى التوتر بين المرتزقه
وهيئه الاركان العامه الروسيه
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
انظمه الدفاع الجويه اعترضت تسعه صواريخ
من رجيمات هي مارس وعشرت مسيرات تابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه على مدار
الساعات الماضيه مؤكده ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه قامت بتدمير مستودعات الذخيره
تابعه لللوائين
او ليلي واين اوكرانيين في مقاطعه خرسون
وافاد مسؤولان محليان عن اصابه مدنيين في
ضربه صاروخيه روسيه على منشات صناعيه في
خركيز
ومن خركيز مفرد العربيه احمد بجاتو كذلك
تنضم لنا من موسكو مراسلات العربيه
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع بجاتو بما ان
التطورات الاخيره تخص خركيف خاصه ميدانيا
وعسكريا احمد هناك استهدافات وهناك كذلك
اشتباكات على الاطراف كيف هي الصوره
نعم مع الاشتباكات اليوم كانت قويه خاصه
تحديدا في منطقه او في مقاطعه خار كيف
يعني سمعنا
الانظار وبعد ذلك كان هناك قصف عده ضربات
صاروخيه استهدفت مناطق في المدينه هنا
تتحدث او يتحدث المسؤولون في خان كيف
الناس استدفت بنيه تحتيه وبعض المباني لا
يوجد سوى اصابتين فقط بالطبع هم يتحفظون
على تحديد الاماكن بالضبط هذه القاعده
المتبعه هنا في كافه او في معظم المناطق
الاوكرانيه
ايضا العسكريون يتحدثون عن ان ال ال مساء
امس واليوم وكذلك يتوقعون خلال اليومين او
الثلاثه القادمه ان يكون هناك ارشادات قوي
للمعارك خاصه في مناطق دونيتس كولجانسك
يعني بالطبع تريد القوات الروسيه احراز
تقدم كبير تتحدث عنه خلال هذه الذكرة
مسؤول الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
يقول انهم يتوقعون ان تقوم روسيا بعمل
كبير لم يحدد نوع هذا العمل لكنهم قال قال
انه يتوقع ان تقوم روسيا بعمل كبير خلال
يومين القادمين لذلك هناك يعني تجديد قوي
واستنفاق امني قوي في وعسكري قوي في مختلف
الجبهات في اوكرانيا
طبع هناك
كانت هناك اشتباكات في خرسون ولحديث الان
عن ان يكون التعليم في كافه المناطق عن
بعد خاصه خلال الايام مع المقبله لكن بصفه
عامه يمكن قول ان عام كامل من يعني الحرب
هنا في خاركين فقد ادى الى الكثير من
الصعوبات للمواطنين قبل قليل كنا نزور احد
الاماكن او احد الاحيان هذا الحي كان
يسكنها الالاف فقط وجدنا بضع عشرات من
المواطنين هؤلاء يعيشون على المساعدات
التي يقدمها المواطنون او المتطوعون لهم
هم يعيشون بلا كهرباء او غاز شح كبير همم
في المياه عمده خرقيف تحدث لنا ان هناك
150 الفا من المواطنين هنا في خرقيف
يعيشون في العراء تحاول السلطات هنا
والسلطه المحليه توفير يعني
وادويه لهؤلاء لكن كل هذا يواجه صعوبه
وصول هذه المساعدات
احمد عن يعني وضع ميداني قوي تشبه
اشتباكات وكذلك استهدافات حتى بالصواريخ
ومن الجهه المقابله في روسيا هناك تصريحات
كذلك قويه اتت هذه المره كاتيا من نائب
رئيس
الامن او مجلس الامن الروسي مدفادف والتي
يعتبر فيها بان روسيا ستصاعد ستدافع عن
نفسها حتى وان كان بال هو قال بكل الطرق
ولم يستثني النووي هل هناك تصريحات اخرى
تفهمنا المقصود من ذلك
مرحبا نارين ما بالفعل يعني هذه هذه
التصريحات ليست هي بالجديده بالنسبه لنائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي هو مرارا هدد
باستخدام روسيا للنووي في حال كان هناك اي
تهديد خارجي تشكله طبعا الى موسكو هو
اليوم تحدث عن طبعا تعليقا على الزياره
التي اجراها الرئيس الامريكي بايدن الى
وارسو هو قال ان روسيا اولا لن تتوقف من
العمليه العسكريه او لو تنهي العمليه
العسكريه الان لانها في حال قامت بذلك
سيؤدي الى تجزيء روسي او انهائها بشكل
كامل اولا اعتبر ان العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه ممكن ان تنتهي فقط في حال توقف
توقفت واشنطن عن دعم اوكرانيا طبعا وقال
ان واشنطن في حال ارادت ان
يكون هناك نظام استراتيجيا مستقرا في
العالم
بالاضافه لذلك انها تريد ان تهزم موسكو لن
يكون هناك طبعا لديها القدره على تحقيق
هذين الهدفين مع معا لانه سيؤدي الى نزاع
عالمي في حال استهدفت او ارادت هزيمه
موسكو وبالاشاره لازالك هو تحدث عن ان
موسكو في حال
احست ان هناك سيكون تهديد لها ستستخدم
جميع الوسائل للدفاع عن نفسها ومن بينها
طبعا النووي كان قد تحدث يوم امس الرئيس
الروسي عن نفس الموضوع وكان قد اوعز الى
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان تكون مستعده
لاجراء تجارب نوويه طبعا في حال احسست ان
هناك من الجانب الامريكي ايضا
تجارب نوويه تجري او في حال احست بالخطر
التي قد يهدد او الذي قد يهدد موسكو طبعا
ريم
روسيا تتحدث عن حمايه نفسها وجوب حمايه
نفسها بكل الوسائل ولكن كذلك بذاته منذ
قليل هناك اجتماع لمجموعه بخارص تسعه
بحضور بايدن بحضور
كما الرئيس الامريكي كذلك اكدوا على
مساعده اوكرانيا بكل الوسائل هم كذلك
وبالتالي بحسب مشاهداتك ما الذي تحتاجه
اوكرانيا ما الذي نقلوه لك الجنود في
الميدان او حتى سكان المناطق الذين
يتابعون تفاصيل العسكريه ما نوعيه
المساعدات التي يحتاجونها
نعم بالطبع المساعدات العسكريه ريم هي
المساعدات الاهم والتي ترغب اوكرانيا في
الحصول عليها تليها بالطبعه المساعدات
المدنيه المساعدات العسكريه هي الاهم
الجنود الروسي يتحدث والمسؤولون ايضا
الجنود الاوكران والمسؤولون الاوكران
يتحدثون انهم مواثقون من النصر على العدو
الروسي على حد وصفهم هم يقولون ان روس
كانوا يروجون انهم يعني سيسيطرون على كيف
ذاتها في خلال ثلاثه ايام لكن مره عام
كامل ولم ينجحوا في السيطره جزء قليل من
المناطق بالعكس قام قام الجيش الاوكراني
بدحر القوات الروسيه في العديد من المناطق
لذلك هم لا يعولون كثيرا على ما يقوله
القاده الروس ولا على ما يقوله بوتين ايضا
هم يقولون انهم تعودوا منهم على هذا
الكلام الذي يحاولون ان يخيفوا به الشعب
الاوكراني والجنود الاوكران لكن هم واثقون
من النصر في النهايه لكن لابد لهذا النصر
من دعم اوروبا
مشاهدينا بعد مرور عام على الحرب
الاوكرانيه اثبتت الارقام انها من اكثر
الحروب الحديثه ضروره تكلفه بشريه
واقتصاديه واسعه منذ الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي
[موسيقى]
في وقت يتصاعد التوتر بين موسكو و واشنطن
هناك تقارب اخر بدات تظهر ملامحه بين
روسيا والصين حيث اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ان وجهات النظر بشان القضايا
الدوليه بين باكين وموسكو متطابقه الى حد
كبير وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو
ترحب بمبادره الصين وترى انها ستلعب دورا
مهما في حل الازمه في اوكرانيا واشارت
موسكو الى تقديرها لموقف الصين بشان قضيه
اوكرانيا ووصفته بالمتوازن
التقارب بين موسكو وبكين اكدته اكثر
تصريحات بوتين الذي قال ان علاقه بلاده مع
الصين مهمه لتهدئه الوضع الدولي واشار الى
ان الوضع الحالي اصعب بكثير بعد انهيار
النظام ثنائي القطب
العلاقات الدوليه اليوم اكثر صعوبه لم
تتحسن بعد انهيار نظام ثنائي القطب بل على
العكس اصبحت اكثر حده في هذا الصدد يلعب
التعامل على الساحه الدوليه بين جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه والاتحاد الروسي كما اكدنا
مرارا وتكرارا دورا مهما في استقرار الوضع
الدولي
بالطبع نحن ننتظر من رئيس جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه ان يقوم بزياره لروسيا اتفقنا على
ذلك في وقت سابق
ومع التقارب بين تكيين وموسكو تتصاعد
التوترات من جهه اخرى بين الصين والولايات
المتحده
رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بانه يقول شيء
ويفعل شيئا اخر وذلك على خلفيه ازمه بالون
التجسس الصيني المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه
قال ان بلاده تامل من بايدن القيامه بما
يقول
تعهد الرئيس بايدن مرارا وتكرارا بانه لا
يسعى لحرب بارده جديده وليس لديه نيه
لصراع مع الصين لكونه زعيم دوله كبرى نامل
ان يفي بكلمته وان يقوم بما يقول بدلا من
قول شيء وفعل شيء اخر نحض الولايات
المتحده مره اخرى على اظهار الصدق وتصحيح
الاخطاء ومواجهه الضرر الناجم عن اساءه
استخدام القوه في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه ومن غير اللائق عدم الرد بالمثل
اذا اصرت الولايات المتحده على الاستفاده
من تصعيد الازمه في الجانب الصيني سيتماشى
مع ذلك حتى النهايه ستتحمل الولايات
المتحده كل العوامل
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعدها سنعود لنتابع
وسط تمديد دولي اسرائيل تصاعد في الضفه
باقتحامها حيا في نابلس مخلفه قتلى وجرحى
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد نستكمل نشره
الخامسه من التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين حيث قتل فلسطينيون برصاص
الجيش الاسرائيلي في عمليه عسكريه متواصله
منذ صباح اليوم في نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
حيث تشهد المدينه مداهمات متكرره كثافتها
اسرائيل على مدار العام الماضي واظهرت
الصور توغل القوات الاسرائيليه في وسط
المدينه ومركبات عسكريه وهي تطلق قنابل
الغاز المسيل للدموع هذا واعلنت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتله عشره واصابه نحو
100 اخرين برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
اقتحامها للبلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس
واوضحت في بيان ان الكثير من الحالات
مصابه برصاص الحي بينما اصيب اكثر من 250
بالاختناق وانسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه من
البلده القديمه في نابلس بعد اقتحامها
الشيخ مسلم وسط اطلاق نار كثيف
[موسيقى]
هذا وحملت رئاسته الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد في نابلس
وطلبت المجتمع الدوليه بالتحرك الفوري
لوقف ممارسات اسرائيل تجاه الفلسطينيين في
هذه الاثناء اعلنت القوى الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه الاضراب الشامل غدا ردا على
التصعيد الاسرائيلي
من نابلس معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ
جعوان عبد الحفيظ اهلا بك معنا اشتباكات
استمرت وتبعناها معك في ساعات طويله منذ
هذا الصباح تسعه قتله حتى الان بحسب
التصريحات الرسميه هل هناك تحديث للاعداد
هناك اطلاق رصاص مطاطي حدثنا عن التفاصيل
عن حفيظ
[تصفيق]
مهما حلا ريم من الحزن الشديد
والحداد على ضحايا الفلسطينيين الذين
قتلتهم القوات الاسرائيليه هذا اليوم في
مدينه نابلس وهم عشره ارتفع العدد وفق
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في اخر تحديث في
هجوم اعتبره الفلسطينيون الاكثر دمويه منذ
سنوات طوال اضافه الى نحو 100 جريح بعضهم
اصابته خطره من هؤلاء الفلسطينيين بعض
التجار وبعض الفتيه الذين كانوا في حاره
الشيخ مسلم في البذره القديمه في مدينه
نابلس عندما داهمت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه
مكان كان يتحصن فيه مقاتلان من عرين
الاسود واللذان رفضا الاستسلام وقضاء
اشتباه مسلحا مع القوات الاسرائيليه بعدها
تم استحضار تعزيزات كبيره من القوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقاموا بقصف المنزل
على من فيه داره اشتباكات عنيفه في مدينه
نابلس في محيط المكان موقع هذا العدد
الكبير من الضحايا ومن الاصابات هناك
استعداد
لتشجيع جثامين الضحايا في موكب تشييع كما
تسمعين هناك اطلاق نار كثيفه هذا يعني
يجري اثناء عمليه تشييع الضحايا وخصوصا من
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين عشرات المقاتلين
سواء من عرين الاسود او بقيه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه يشاركون في هذا التشييع
ويتوعدون ايضا برد او بعمليات فرد عسكريه
على هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي الكبير عبد
الحفيظ كانت هناك معلومات او دعوات على
الاقل على ما وقع التواصل الاجتماعي بخروج
في مسيرات بعد تشييع الجسمي تؤكد لنا ذلك
وما المنتظر في الساعات القادمه
ان كنت فهمت السؤال يا ريم نعم هناك دعوات
من كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه اولا هناك
دعوات بالاضراب والحداد العام المدارس
ستغلق الجامعات ستغلق يوم غدا وهناك دعوات
لتظاهرات في مختلف المدن الفلسطينيه ايضا
هذا اليوم كما تشاهدين من مدينه نابلس
مغلقه بشكل كامل ومعظم المدن الفلسطينيه
مغلقه هناك دعوات من الفصائل للخروج في
مسيرات هناك ايضا دعوات في قطاع غزه ويمكن
ان نشهد تصعيدا ايضا في قطاع غزه الفصل
الفلسطينيه تتواعد بالرد باطلاق صواريخ
ايضا
من عمليات فرديه قد يكون فيها فلسطينيون
ردا على هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي ايضا هناك
تصريحات سياسيه مندده بشكل كبير لما جرى
وخصوصا ان هذه العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تاتي وسط حديث عن تطمينات
امريكيه وتامينات دوليه بان يعني مسار
التفاهمات من الجانب الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي
يجري بشكل جيد وان ضمانات امريكيه قد وصلت
للجانب الفلسطيني بان اسرائيل لن تجري
عمليات اقتحام واسعه للمدن الفلسطينيه
يعني وكما جرى في نابلس نابلس واحده من
كبرى المدن الفلسطينيه عدد سكانها اكثر
200 الف ان يجري هذا الاقتحام في وضح
النهار الساعه العاشره وسط دوام المدارس
والجامعات وان يوقع هذا العدد الكبير من
الضحايا هذا من شانها ان يؤتي بردود فعل
كبيره فلنشاهدها من الجانب الفلسطيني
وسننتظر هذا التصعيد ومال هذا التصعيد
خلال الساعات والايام القادمه
سنبقى في متابعه لهذه الصوره وهذه
التطورات ولكن عاد حفيظ اختم معك فقط
بحديثك عن ان كانت هناك اشتباكات مستمره
هذه العمليه انتهت ولكن كنا لاحظنا بان
هذه العمليه تخللتها كذلك
وتوالت معها الشباكات هل هذا مستمر
لا الاشتباكات توقفت هذه الاشتباكات نعم
كان هناك مقاتلين من من عرين الاسود وايضا
مختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه كما تشاهدين
يعني هؤلاء مقاتلين من عارين الاسود
ومختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه خاضوا
الاشتباكات صباح هذا اليوم مع القوات
الاسرائيليه بعضهم من بين كان من بين
الضحايا ولكنهم حسب البيانات التي وصلتنا
منهم فهم مستمرون في مواجهه اي اقتحام
اسرائيلي ويدعون ايضا لمزيد من المقاومه
مزيد من التصدي لعمليات الاقتحام
الفلسطينيه للمدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من نابلس مراسل العربيه عبد
الحفيظ
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعده سنعود لنتابع
وزير الدفاع باكستاني يدعو حكومه طالبان
افغانستاني لكبحي جماحي فرع الحركه
بباكستان
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قال السفير
السعودي لدى اليمن محمد الجبر للعربيه ان
الوديعه السعوديه الجديده هي جزء من حزمه
لدعم الاقتصاد والتنميه في اليمن اضافه
الى تحقيق استقرار سعر الصرف باليمن
من الدعم التنموي والاقتصادي للاشقاء في
اليمن
هو مجموعه من الدعم تتكامل مع بعضها البعض
في خدمه الانسان اليمني وخدمه الاقتصاد
اليمني ودعم مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني
ليقوم بدوره هو والحكومه اليمنيه في خدمه
الانسان اليمني ومواجهه التحديات الصعبه
التي حقيقه يعانون منها بشكل كبير جدا
فالحزمه مكونه من مليار دولار من المملكه
ومليار دولار من الامارات المملكه اودعت
بالامس مليار دولار في البنك المركزي
اليمني وهذا سيساعد في دعم الاقتصاد
استقرار سعر الصرف هذا سيساعد ايضا التجار
والرجال الاعمال في القدره على الشراء
واستيراد وخاص المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه
الملف الايرانيه الان حيث اذان المستشار
الالمانيه
ضد مواطن الماني المزدوج الجنسيه وطالب
بالغاء القرار من جهتها اكدت الخارجيه
الالمانيه انها ستدعم المواطنه الالماني
كما استدعت القائمه بالاعمال الايراني
وسلامته احتجاجا على حكم اعدام بحق
مواطنيها المدان وذكر بيان الخارجيه
الالمانيه ايضا ان برلين قررت طرد اثنين
من موظفي السفاره الايرانيه ردا على هذا
الحكم
في تداعي يتزلزل المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا في
السادس من فبراير الجاري اطلقت انقره
برنامجا مؤقتا لدعم الاجور وحضرت تسريح
الموظفين في عشر مدن لحمايه الموظفين
والشركات من التداعيات الماليه للهزات
الارضيه المدمره التي ضربت البلاد وقال
مصدر رسمي تركي ان الشركات التي تعرضت
مقراتها لاضرار شديده او متوسطه ستستفيد
من الدعم الذي سيذهب جزء منه لتغطيه اجور
العاملين الذين تقلصت ساعه عملهم
[موسيقى]
فيما تسابق السلطات التركيه الزمن لازاله
اثار الدمار الذي لحق بها تاي وباقي المدن
المتضرره من الزلزال تطفو الى سطح ركام
مئاسي انسانيه تحتاج الى سنوات من النسيان
مفدى العربيه الى هاتاي يلتقى رجلا سوريا
نجا من تحت الانقاض ودخل في رحله بحث عن
ابنه الذي يامل في ان يكون الناجي الوحيد
من عائلته مفرد العربي عبد القادر خربوش
نقل لنا هذه التفاصيل
عرفه الله ما بعرف
ذهبت
منهكا مكسورا فاقدا للحيله امامها للواقع
او ان نجحت خطط ازاله هذا الدمار الذي
خلفه الزلزال سريعا ستظل قصص ماسيه مستمره
مااس انسانيه لاشخاص امثال عمر ماتت زوجته
وابنه تحت هذا الركام فيما نجا هو ودخل
لحظتها في رحله بحث عن ابنه الثاني
المفقود
هاي لعبه
اليوم يقول ليتني ما نجوت ايقاف فرق
الانقاذ بحثها عن ابنه المفقود بعد تيقنها
من عدم وجوده تحت هذه الانقاذ منحه املا
في العثور عليه حيه والغرفه الصالون
فتشنا بكل البيت ما لقينا شيء
الديوانات
والسداجه طلعت وابني ما طلع ابني
[موسيقى]
تميت يومين لطلعت والحمد لله رب العالمين
بتمنى من الجميع اني اعرف
صاحب البيت يشوف هالمكان ويعرف يعرفني انه
انا عايش اذا ابني معه يا رب يجيبه او
يعطيني خبر عليه
تمضي الساعات والايام وربما الاسابيع لكن
الزمن عند عمر متوقف الى حين لقاء ابنه
شعله امله الوحيده للحياه
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
في اعقاب الزلزال المدمر اعلن المرصد
السوري وارتفاع حصيله ضحايا زلزال السادس
من فبراير في الشمال السوري الى قرابه
و750 شخصا فيما لا يزال المئات بحاله حرجه
ما يشير الى ان الاعداد مرشحه للزياده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من ريف ادلب مراسل العربيه محمد الاشقر
محمد اهلا بك معنا صعوبات لم نقل ماسي
حقيقيه انسانيه
يعيشها سكان المنطقه هل من مساعدات تصل
وما ظروف عيش بالاساس
نعم يعني ماساه حقيقيه يعيشها هنا معظم
المتضررون من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا في السادس من الشهر الجاري
طبعا عموم المناطق هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
منطقه واسعه جدا تمتد من ريف اللاذقيه الى
مدينه جرابلس هذه المنطقه الواسعه هناك
العديد من القرى والبلدات التي طالها
الضرر وطالعها ونالت نصيبها من الدمار
واعداد الضحايا والعائلات المتضرره التي
لم تذكر للاسف الى حد هذه اللحظه الى
الاعلام يعني في الحقيقه المساعدات
الانسانيه التي وصلت سرعان ما تتجه الى
مراكز الايواء التي استقبلت المتضررين
والى المخيمات المستحدثه ولكن هناك العديد
من العائلات مئات العائلات التي لحد هذه
اللحظه تعاني ولا تزال تبحث عن ماوى هناك
مثلا في قريه هيتيا في ريف ادلب الغربي
هناك اكثر من 15 عائله اضطروا لازاله
الركام من ركاب منازلهم ونصب
قيام من بقايا المنزل اي انهم رفعوا جدران
الخيمه ببعض احجار منازلهم
وصنعوا خيام بانشفهم ولكن انا تصلهم
مساعدات محمد
ليست هناك او من يشرف على ايصال هذه
المساعدات الى الداخل
نعم يعني في الحقيقه ان تحدثنا عن
المساعدات فهناك العديد من المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه والفرق الشبابيه
التطوعيه التي تسعى جاهزه
للمساعدات للمتضررين ولكن هناك العديد من
المناطق العديد من المتضررين الذين لم
تصلهم الى حد هذه اللحظه المساعدات وان
تحدثنا عن المساعدات الامميه فقد دخلت
اليوم سته عشر حافله جديده محمله
بالمساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه من الامم
المتحده اغلب هذه الشاحنات محمله
بالمساعدات الانسانيه كاسله الغذائيه
وهناك ثلاثه شاحنات فقط محمله بالخيام
طبعا المساعدات الامميه يشرف على توزيعها
وايصالها للمتضررين منظمات محليه شريكه
للامم المتحده تعمل هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
منذ سنوات شكرا جزيلا لك محمد الاشقر
مراسل العربيه من رفيق ادلب
الى ملف اخر حيث قالت حكومه طالبان انه
على باكستان حل قضاياها الداخليه دون
القاء اللون علينا وان كابل تشكل اي خطر
او تهديد ضد اي دوله ومنها باكستان من
جهته دعوه وزير الدفاع الباكستاني دعا
طالبان افغانستان الى لعب دور لوقف
الهجمات الارهابيه كما طلب الوزير الحركه
بكبح جماح فرع هابي باكستان
لبنان تعتبر داره الايتام الاسلاميه اكبر
دار رعايه احتضنت الاطفال وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه منذ اكثر من قرن ولكن ومع بدايه
الازمه الاقتصاديه في البلاد بات الفقر
السبب الرئيسي والاساسي الذي يدفع
الاهاليل ايداع اطفالهم في الدار لعدم
تمكنهم من تامين المتطلبات الاساسيه لهم
يستقبل جمال والدته بعد غياب اسبوعين هي
الام التي تربي ولديها وحيده بعد انفصالها
عن الوالد
اضطرت مع تفاقم الازمه الاقتصاديه لتركهما
في دار الايتام الاسلاميه
ساعات طويله تمضيها ريهام في العمل الا
انها غير قادره على تامين اساسيات العيش
الكريم صعب كتير وما بتتعود عليه هذا
الموضوع يعني ما في مجال تتعود عليه بس
لانه البعد عنك اول ما بنحطه اكيد ما
تقبلوا الموضوع واكيد بصير في لوم على
الاهل انه انتم بدكم تتركونا من وقت ما
غلي كل شيء بالبلد من وقت ما صرنا حتى نحن
وبنشتغل ما نقدر نكفي حاجات اولادنا
اضطرينا نحطهم بدون ليساعدونا ان كان من
ناحيه التعليم ولا من ناحيه الاكل والشرب
وغيره
هذا العام مع طفاكم الازمه الاقتصاديه
اوضعت 500 عائله اطفالها في مراكز دار
الايتام المنتشره على مختلف المناطق
اللبنانيه لعدم تمكنها من تامين معيشتهم
ومع غلاء اسعار الوقود يضطر الاطفال
للوقوف هنا لاسابيع طويله
بعضهم يذهبوا الى مدارس رسميه اعلنت
اضرابها قبل شهرين الامر الذي زاد من
المعانت اليوم هذه الازمه اصبحت 80% من
الاسر في لبنان هي ما دون خط الفقر وفي
الفقر المتقع هذه الاسر اليوم اللي عم
تاتي باولادها الى دار الرعايه الى دار
الايتام لحتى تامنهم الماوى الملبس الماكل
والتعليم والصحه ما عادت قادره هذه الاسره
ان تقوم بهذه الوجبات بيحكوا على حالات عم
بياتي فيها الاولاد كان الحالات من سوء
التغذيه او حالات من قله يعني النظافه
والصحه والى اخره
لو قد ما قدمنا نحنا وقد ما كان المكان
اللي قاعد فيه مريح وحلو ومناسب بس بحس
انه بده عيلته بده الاسره اللي هو
عم تشكل شوي صعوبات سلوكيا بالولد يعودوا
تاريخه دار الايتام الى اكثر من قرن كانت
تعتمد على تبرعات المجتمع المحلي ووزاره
الشؤون الاجتماعيه
لكنها فقدت سبل الدعم ما يضعها امام خطر
وجودي يؤدي الى فقدان سته الاف طالب مؤسسه
كانت ملجاهم في وقت الشده لطالما كانت هذه
الدار ملجا للمحتاجين لكنها اليوم بحاجه
الى من يدعمها لرعايه اطفال باتوا في عمق
الازمه غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت
بهذا التقرير ننهي نشره الخامسه لليوم لكن
دائما العربي شكرا على المتابعه والسلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]